happiest season is a really heartwarming
christmas story
about two women who are very much in
love
come with me to my parents house for
christmas abby you and harper have a
perfect
relationship this is very old-fashioned
but i'm going to ask your dad for his
blessing and propose on christmas
morning
way to stick to the patriarchy really
well done
happiest season just felt like a great
opportunity to tell
a universal story from a new perspective
i have always been
a big fan of holiday movies but i had
never seen
my experience represented there's
something that we should talk about
hi i didn't tell my parents i'm gay so
who do they think i am this is harper's
orphan friend
abby yes of course they're there you're
so brave
you don't need to be in many ways it's
just a great
traditional holiday movie and in other
ways
is a little bit groundbreaking because
there's never been
a holiday movie with two women who are
in love at the center of it
if there was ever an lgbtq character in
a movie
they were always in the background if
they were there at all just be yourself
but don't lie
you're a bad liar riley harper this is
abby
abby is my orphan roommate we
i am an orphan but we live together as
friends
um like acquaintances yeah having
mainstream classics about a love
story like this is so important i think
any gay woman over the age of 20 years
old right now has probably
dealt with not being able to be honest
about who you are being with someone
who's not quite ready to be honest about
who they are
so her parents believe their straight
daughter brought home her lesbian
friend for christmas not exactly they
also think that i'm straight
have they ever met a lesbian in writing
the script
we definitely wanted it to be a comedy
but still
have a groundedness to it and felt
relatable i can relate to being in love
with somebody that is too afraid to show
the world who they are
what are you doing in the closet it'll
mean a lot to a lot of people out there
i think there's a lot of people who have
not seen themselves represented
in holiday films like this i am scared
that if i tell them who i really am i
will lose them
do you know how painful it's been to
watch the person that i love hide me i
am not hiding you
i am hiding me we live in a diverse
world
we need much more love and tolerance and
acceptance this movie is
all about that it's really exciting
being a part of this
it's time that our mainstream films
reflected more accurately what society
actually looks like
this movie was made with a tremendous
amount of
love and heart everybody's story is
different
just because harper isn't ready doesn't
mean she doesn't love you
i really hope that the people who watch
it can feel how much we thought
of them and how much we cared about them
while we were putting this movie
together
i really hope that it's a welcome
addition to the to the holiday canon
of of movies that people watch year
after year
you're the only girl i've got on my list